nos piden que encontremos estos tres
límites como siempre los invito a que
pause en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
antes de que lo hagamos juntos cuando
vemos el primero probablemente tratamos
de encontrar el límite cuando x tiende a
menos 2 de fx y luego el de eje x y
sumar esos límites pero rápidamente
encontramos un problema al calcular el
límite de fx cuando x tiende a menos 2
desde la izquierda efe x se acerca a 1
cuando nos acercamos a x es igual a
menos 2 desde la derecha parece que el
valor de la función se acerca a 3 parece
que el límite de fx a medida que x se
acerca a menos 2 no existe y lo mismo
ocurre con g x si nos acercamos desde la
izquierda parece que nos estamos
acercando a 3 si nos acercamos desde la
derecha parece que nos estamos acercando
a 1 pero resulta que este límite puede
seguir existiendo mientras exista el
límite cuando x tiende a menos 2 desde
la izquierda de la suma de fx más g x
existe si es igual al límite cuando
existiendo menos 2 desde la derecha de
la suma de fx más gx cuál es el
resultado de esto bueno a medida que nos
acercamos a menos cosas de la izquierda
fx se acerca a 1 ig x se acerca a 3 así
que parece que nos estamos acercando a 1
y a 3 la suma de 1 y 3 es 4 y si venimos
de la derecha fx parece acercarse a 3 y
gtx parece acercarse a 1 una vez más la
suma es igual a 4 y dado que los límites
del lado izquierdo y derecho se acercan
a la misma cosa diríamos que este límite
si existe y es igual a 4 ahora hagamos
el siguiente ejemplo cuando x tiende a 1
cuando haremos exactamente el mismo
ejercicio y una vez más si nos fijamos
en los límites individuales para f x
desde la izquierda y la derecha a medida
que nos acercamos a 1 este límite no
existe pero el límite cuando x tiende a
1 de la suma puede existir así que
así que el límite cuando x tiende a 1
desde el lado izquierdo de fx gx a que
va a ser igual
entonces f x cuando nos acercamos a 1
desde la izquierda parece que se acerca
a 2 estoy haciendo esto para abreviar y
g x cuando nos acercamos a 1 desde la
izquierda parece que se acerca a 0
entonces esto es 2 + 0 que es igual a 2
y luego el límite cuando x tiende a 1
desde el lado derecho de fx gx es igual
a bueno para f x cuando nos acercamos a
1 desde el lado derecho parece que se
acerca a menos 1 y para gm x cuando nos
acercamos a 1 desde el lado derecho
parece que nos acercamos a 0 otra vez
aquí parece que nos acercamos a menos 1
por lo tanto los límites del lado
izquierdo y derecho no se acercan al
mismo valor por lo que este límite no
existe y el último pero no menos
importante el límite de fx cuando x
tiende a 1
de x x que de x vamos a hacer el mismo
ejercicio límite cuando x tiende a 1
desde el lado izquierdo de fx x que de x
bueno aquí incluso podemos usar los
valores que ya tenemos vemos que se
acerca a 1 desde la izquierda nos
acercamos a 2 así que esto es 2 y aquí
cuando nos acercamos a 1 desde la
izquierda nos acercamos a 0 nos
acercamos a 2 x 0 que es 0 y luego nos
acercamos desde la derecha x tiende a 1
desde la derecha de fx x gx bueno ya
vimos que cuando tiende a 1 desde la
derecha
f x se acerca a menos 10 g de x cuando
se acerca a 1 desde la derecha sigue
acercándose a 0 por lo que este será
nuevamente 0 de modo que este límite
existe obtenemos el mismo límite cuando
nos acercamos desde la izquierda y desde
la derecha es igual a 0 así que estos
son ejemplos bastante interesantes
porque a veces piensas que los límites
componentes no existen eso
significa que la suma o el producto
podría no existir pero esto muestra al
menos dos ejemplos donde ese no es el
caso
hasta el próximo vídeo